we are at the academy Oscars outdoor
space in Hollywood tonight we are
screening julie and julia in honor of my
friend and of course there are many food
trucks serving their take on what Julie
or Julia might have enjoyed I was a
teenager when a Julia Child first made
her appearance on television she was a
huge influence on me because I was
already a fluky and was already trying
to teach myself from cookbooks so she
was an enormous influence everything she
did influenced me in ways that I didn't
even really understand until I saw the
movie the biggest challenge was making
Meryl who's really miss high that so we
built ramps we made walkways truly she
was walked across a room she would
always be walking raised and we'd have
the cameras up to hide that you couldn't
you've cut her at the knees he couldn't
see that she was actually walking on
little boards that people we put up on
Apple boxes I brought Nora's cookbook
which in some ways is like a invitation
from the Academy there are very few
people who were lucky enough to get one
I was before she died Nora Ephron said
one of the things she would miss the
most about no longer being alive was pie
but when it came to pie she didn't want
to make pie crust in fact her recipe for
apple pie and her own cookbook says by a
nice Pillsbury pie crust in your local
market and then she went on to the
recipe itself there's a thing that was
referred to in her house as turkey
spaghetti
which sounds awful and it's spaghetti
with cream sauce with turkey liverwurst
peas and mushrooms in a cream sauce and
it sounds disgusting it's amazing
working with Nora was one of the
greatest experiences of my life if you
can imagine the joy of working with your
best friend
you know eating and shopping
in the end I realized that that's the
ideal relationship between a director
and producer to be able to want to see
each other at the end of dailies and
wanted review today and talk about the
next day and what went wrong what went
right and what she might want to reshoot
and what she was happy with what she
wasn't I think if Nora Ephron was at
your dinner party even if the food was
lousy it was going to be a great night